here we go chris and look as we tape
this full transparency it's 10 20 a.m
eastern on monday the market is due to
open at noon eastern the unofficial
start of free agency where teams can
work out deals that won't become
official until the league year begins
the nfl intends to go forward the nfl
has tried to blame it on the nfl players
association demora smith the nfl pa
executive director was on espn earlier
today and said hey
don't blame us we didn't say don't do it
so there's still a chance the nfl is
gonna do the right thing the smart thing
the prudent thing and slam on the brakes
but assuming it goes forward chris this
is gonna be a free agency period unlike
any we've seen because if the national
quarantine hits before wednesday at 4 pm
eastern these tentative deals are gonna
remain tentative for weeks maybe months
yeah weeks maybe months that leaves a
lot of time for a guy to get hurt in the
meantime i mean there's just too many
things that are unknown right now you
know i i really and even listen i think
my big thought is this even if this goes
goes along as planned right now where it
looks like like you said 12 o'clock it's
gonna start here we go
i i think we're gonna see maybe a rush
with the top-end guys that get signed as
usual
but i think after that you're going to
see a halt in progress or signings or
anything like that i mean that's just my
sense i just know and i know i've texted
you this throughout the weekend people
in the nfl were annoyed that free agency
is continuing right now i don't think
any everybody's out of the routine
people got kicked out of the facility
you know people are all over the place
all over the country stuck in certain
cities whatever it may be
i just think everything's a little
unorganized right now and i think
everybody has a plan to what they want
to do to be aggressive to start free
agency and then you adjust as you go
through free agency and i think that's
when we're going to see a halt in
progress right there
and i really don't know
what the
nfl is thinking by proceeding with this
they know it's not the right thing to do
otherwise they wouldn't be trying to
blame the nfl players association and if
the nflpa truly is responsible for
pushing this forward at a certain point
you tell them tough [ __ ] right you say
we're going for we are stopping this and
if you don't like it file a charge with
the national labor relations board that
we are engaging in improper bargaining
by by
unilaterally imposing this
material change to the work terms
look these are these are strange times
and it calls for
unusual measures and i i feel like the
nfl doesn't know why it wants to go
forward i don't know why it wants to go
forward no one has explained to me why
it wants to go forward the only argument
chris you can make for going forward is
it's only going to get worse not better
so we may as well do it now i don't know
that that's a good reason to go forward
well okay i get you you're right that
does seem to be one of the reasons i
don't think that's a good reason either
though i'm in a total agreement with you
there but i think as we both know we've
both got a lot of uh play on social
media where guy i've seen many people
you know tweet at me on instagram you
know there's nothing going on right now
people are starving for something else
other than the coronavirus i think the
nfl you know right or wrong
uh realizes that they're smart as we
know these are some of the greatest
business people we've seen and selfishly
even me in these weird times i'm bored
right now i mean come on i'm sitting in
my damn family room talking to you on a
freaking phone all right there's
something i'd like to do i would like to
see some action selfishly but you're
right they got to be sensitive to the
whole country here and you know as you
mentioned many times what's it going to
look like on a day where people are
starting to lose paychecks and all of a
sudden guys like jedevian clowney are
going to get 50 million dollar checks
right that's to where i think the nfl
needs to be careful and then to your
other point where the nfl would just say
hey screw you we're halting procedures
go ahead nflpa file agreements and let's
see where that goes i mean you're right
that's a very real possibility and
really
is the nflpa in these sensitive times
really going to do that you know and say
oh okay yeah we're going to go forward
with a insensitive fight to the american
public here and we want to go on with
free agency why the nfl is saying no i
don't think that would necessarily be a
look for a good look for the nflpa
either so uh i i don't know i just think
the nfl is stubborn and they're going to
continue to go with this because they
know they're the biggest show in town
right now
you mentioned to davey and clowney
that's a prime example of a guy who's
not going to get any play until he can
be given a physical right right he's not
going to get an agreement in principle
and why would you take an agreement in
principle let's play this out you do an
agreement in principle at 1201 pm
eastern today it becomes final when you
pass a physical national quarantine is
imposed between now and wednesday at 4
pm eastern there's no way to get a
physical so
this deal is in limbo clowney is in
limbo until the quarantine is lifted
until he can go get a physical and then
who knows what the physical is going to
produce and you know as well as i do
chris that the doctors who are hired by
the teams are going to give the teams
whatever results they want on the
physical what if whoever does an
agreement in principle with clowney
today decides between now and whenever
you know what we got a better option we
got a better plan we really don't want
to do this deal with clowney he's going
to fail the physical and he's back on
the market at that point starting all
over again that's the risk that that's
that's one of the dangers of allowing
the market to start now you can't get
the physical done quickly and you let
teams sit around and think about other
things they can do and they can
eventually screw a guy who thinks that
money is coming into his bank account
well yeah definitely and then i think
more to the time we're in right now like
is it going to be a little weird if a
guy like your deviant clown is going
through a hospital and using up doctors
like i saw you write this yesterday i
believe you know is that going to be
cool when a guy like devion county goes
into a hospital and consumes like four
or five medical professionals in a time
like this where we know we're you know a
little short on those things and of
course being very aware of our medical
access and and hoping we're ready for
this onslaught that we think might be
coming with coronavirus and then added
to your fact mike which i mean you may
make great points is if you're a team
that does sign it let's say a gedevian
county or a guy that you might have some
concern about some injury and you can't
give them that physical right now
because of all the things that are going
on how can you really proceed with the
rest of free agency with oh we have this
money allotted for this guy but we're
not really sure he's on our team yet and
we wanted to get this other position but
things didn't work out and now we have
to overpay for another guy i just have a
hard time figuring out how teams are
going to juggle the plans going forward
after this if you can't get all these
little details done like of course a
medical evaluation for guys that have a
little bit of an injury history and
you're going to pay big money too
and here's the last thing i'm going to
say about it before we move on in 2011
the nfl delayed free agency until august
as part of the work stoppage a fairly
ordinary lockout that resulted in a deal
being done in free agency happening just
a couple of days after that new cba was
signed well if the nfl can delay free
agency that long delay until after the
draft in order to advance its own
interests the nfl can do the same damn
thing chris in the name of respecting
and advancing the greater good and
that's what i want to see from this
institution that i have been following
for the last 50 years that i have been
covering for the last 20 years at times
like this we need our great institutions
to lead from ahead not from behind and i
am very disappointed with the way the
nfl has handled this because it's
short-sighted it's selfish and it's not
stepping up and standing up and doing
the right thing and i still hold out
hope that by the time anyone out there
sees this the nfl will have realized the
best outcome is to press pause all those
fans who are demanding like veruca salt
they want it now sometimes you don't get
it now but you will get it later all
right tom waiting oh wait wait hold on
one second there just one more thing to
that but i mean i don't you know i'm
just asking i don't know
but i we do have a lot of fans that want
to see it continue and go on here i mean
is it i you know i i struggle with it is
it good or is it insensitive a little
bit i know i think well
yeah they crave normalcy and i don't i
don't fault them for that but it's not
practical there are a lot of things
people want to do at this time so they
can feel like life is going on they want
to have some control over their
existence they go out and buy all the
toilet paper that is a manifestation of
this desire to control and having
something normal and having a
distraction for everything is going on
it's understandable but i don't think
it's the right thing to do it's not
right for the players it's not right for
the team it's not right for the current
circumstances because i don't want
something there's too many people out
there who still think this is no big
deal they think it's just the flu they
think it's all a hoax so the more things
that are disrupted the more the message
gets through to them chris
that this isn't normal do not go about
your normal life get the message to
adjust accordingly and and that's one of
the big reasons why this should not go
forward
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports